it just confirmed everything I had been
thinking for a year and by the way it's
not just Yasmin and Dave who woke up
that night I mean we know we know I
personally know dozens of people that
had it happened to them that night that
have reached out to me but thousands of
people all over the world I got messages
from people literally in Egypt who had
said to me I think you know one of the
guys that I'm talking about in Egypt
actually who said that was my moment to
when I saw hope the the left these guys
have completely abandoned reason and
liberalism and the rest of it Dave don't
burn this book bestseller all over the
place fantastic reviews amazing how are
you feeling today I'm still a pretty
good I'm feeling pretty good but before
we talk about me I want to talk about
you because you're you're leading this
thing who are you what are we doing here
today people know about me
come on Yasmine give yourself some
credit yeah people should know me from
your show I'm I've been on your show
like three times so I'm a veteran Yasmin
Muhammad and I'm the author of unveiled
which is strategically placed behind me
there how Western liberals
empower radicalism and and I run an
organization called free hearts free
minds which supports people who have
left Islam but are stuck in
muslim-majority countries where they
could be executed for doing so and the
thing that we have in common actually is
that we both well you dedicated your
book to Ben Affleck he's not started
I didn't dedicate it to him but he is in
the acknowledgments of my book because
both of us share that same experience of
us deciding that we wanted to change our
lives upon watching the episode of Real
Time with Bill Maher with him with Ben
Affleck and Sam Harris and the famous
gross and racist episode
that was a huge pivotal moment for you
and it was a huge pivotal moment for me
as well and of course gross and racist
over the years you know kept on
escalating until it ended up becoming
Nazi which is the title of chapter four
which we're going to be talking about
today which is don't worry you're not a
Nazi yes you are probably not a Nazi if
you purchased my book that was what I
was trying to get across people but I
love the fact that we've discussed this
on my show several times that your
wake-up call we come from such different
backgrounds Geographic places you live
in Canada now like all sorts of stuff
you were married to a member of al Qaeda
like all of these things that are so
different about us and yet we both by
watching a Hollywood actor overly a moat
and yell instead of reason and
especially because he was doing it
against Bill Maher like our number-one
lefty in America for the last three
decades and Sam Harris who I've told you
I didn't even know who he was until that
night it was the first time I had ever
seen the guy but I saw this
mild-mannered you know nice sharp suit
calm atheist explaining things and then
that overly emotional sort of craziness
and rush to call somebody racist
forget gross but racist it just
confirmed everything I had been thinking
for a year and by the way it's not just
Yasmin and Dave who woke up that night I
mean we know we know I personally know
dozens of people that had it happened to
them that night that have reached out to
me but thousands of people all over the
world I got messages from people
literally in Egypt who had said to me I
think you know one of the guys that I'm
talking about in Egypt actually who said
that was my moment to when I saw hope
the the left these guys have completely
abandoned reason and liberalism and the
rest of it yeah and I think that they're
you know my family being from Egypt as
well the conversation that they were
talking about was about people who have
left Islam in Egypt close to 90% of
people there hold in a Pew poll said
that they think that we should be
executed so as
very personal to me as an ex-muslim of
Egyptian descent same like the person
who communicated with you as well and so
to see these two men on you know
national television going on like
mainstream media talking about us as if
we matter you know which was so amazing
because you never see that all you ever
see is conversations about the
fundamentalist Muslims or the mainstream
Muslims but nobody's ever talking about
the victims within the victims
nobody's ever talking about LGBT Muslims
nobody's ever talking about women under
Islam nobody's ever talking about people
that left us them but are stuck in these
countries or being ostracized by their
communities or disowned by their
families threatened with death like I
was and some people actually being
killed by their families for leaving is
that that conversation never happens so
to see those guys having that
conversation was really amazing and it
was very very sad to see Ben Affleck
shutting it down so when I titled that
chapter you know I had it's obviously
tongue-in-cheek don't worry you're not a
Nazi but I did think oh my critics are
gonna open this thing up they're gonna
go he had to title one of the chapters
don't worry you're not a Nazi because so
many of his fans or whatever our readers
are Nazis but I felt that I just sort of
had to go at it like that but but the
reason that I wanted to do this chapter
with you specifically is that it's one
thing I mean the absurd level that they
call someone like me a Nazi who
everything I stand for is against the
type of collectivist ideology that the
Nazis brought upon the world I grew up
around Holocaust survivors and the rest
of it but someone like you who has as I
you're the only person that I wrote the
inscription to that you publicly
publicly posted it and I shared it
because you are in essence what a true
liberal is supposed to be and you
because you lived through oppression and
now you fight for freedom it's it's a
beautiful thing and you also are called
a Nazi and a bigot and I'm sure all
sorts of self-hating this that and the
other thing yeah and in your chapter you
refer to the journalist from Der Spiegel
yeah you were there that day I was there
that day you know he accused you of
being a Nazi because you had an espresso
machine and all of this ridiculous stuff
you know well no he article let's not
forget in the article he didn't say I
have an espresso machine he said he has
an Italian coffee maker Richard the
implication and and he said Scandinavian
furniture I have an espresso machine I
can't a couch yeah absolutely and it's
laughable but it's also incredibly
hurtful and infuriating the way he was
so condescending and not only was he
telling you what you think and feel he
was telling me what I think and feel
like he was talking he's like a Dave
made Yasmin talk about all of the bad
things in Islam as if Yasmin loves us
then like I'm just waiting for someone
to give me a microphone so I can talk
about all the bad things in that
religion you didn't make me do anything
and that really upsets me you know as
somebody who as you mentioned got away
from being married to a al Qaeda agent
and I have fought tooth and nail as a
single mother with a high school
education to be the woman I am today and
then to have some POS who didn't even
talk to me
be so condescending and and talk about
as if I am a puppet and you got your
hand at me and telling me what to say
and do do you know what I mean I was so
upset in and her so-called marriage to
an al-qaida agent well this dude if he's
a journalist he can very easily look up
that information as I mentioned a song
was very high-ranking his his you know
the court case of him being imprisoned
in Egypt is one of the second largest
court cases in Egyptian history after
the assassination of President Sadat so
it wouldn't have been difficult for him
to confirm my story but instead he just
wanted to be condescending and rude and
patronizing and it's unfortunate that
you have to put up with people like that
so what do we do about that
that thing where it's like the people
that don't want other people to be heard
then call you a Nazi and a bigot and the
rest of it and gross and racist and then
we know that there's this journalist
class and that's why I included this
story because you know they they
literally put me on the print cover of
Der Spiegel and I you know I have a
giant American flag in our control room
because I know it sounds crazy and
nationalist or something a racist but
I'm proud to be an American and they
took a picture of me and I'm sitting
like this with the American flag Miami
and I think the title of the article was
the grand illusionist of the all right
and one of the tricks that this again
journalist did was that there's actually
a law in Germany that if you interview
someone if you're gonna print any of
their quotes you have to run the quotes
by them so this guy who spent from 8
a.m. to 9 p.m. with me because I did two
interviews that day and then I did an
event at USC that night he spends hours
with me and then didn't quote me once in
the piece because he knew he would have
had to run those quotes by me but
instead he gets me with the American
flag behind me and you talked bad about
Islam and it paint and I've got an
Italian coffee maker and this is one
I don't even love the Nespresso machine
frankly I like a Frenchman best better
that's a that's decided you but but that
they craft a narrative as dirt as
journalists but then that then feeds
this Nazi thing so that they can turn to
someone like you and just say the most
awful things even though you're the one
that actually has survived the the
negative parts of both all the parts of
authoritarianism are negative but really
the the terrible the terrible truth that
is the thing you escaped yeah but I
think it's interesting that you that
they didn't take any quotes from you
because that's exactly what it is they
crafted a narrative about who Dave Rubin
is and they crafted a narrative so much
smaller extent in that article of who
Yasmin Muhammad is without any input
from who we actually are it's just
completely fabricated um but actually to
try and bring this to something
productive a question that I get a lot
that I'm gonna pose to you now is you
know what Yasmin I totally agree with
what you're saying I really want to
speak out more but I'm afraid I'm
concerned about my workplace
sometimes I'm concerned about my family
I'm concerned about my spouse I'm
concerned about friends how can I speak
out without having people maliciously
call me these things fabricate a
narrative about Who I am and start to
you know have people react to the
narrative verses to me so what can I do
because right now I'm just biting my
tongue because I see no way out of this
conundrum what can you say to those
people well in many ways that's the
message of the book more than anything
else when I say think for yourself while
thinking for yourself if you're gonna
actually speak it to which is the next
step once you're thinking it is you're
gonna get this stuff and what I tried to
lay out in the book is a roadmap for
what will happen you will be called a
Nazi you will be called a bigot and a
racist and a homophobe I get called a
homophobe I mean married to a dude you
know but put that as
once you get all the Nazi with your
family our Holocaust survivors and you
know why not be a homophobe to again
nothing to do with you these are just
fabricated things yeah yeah I have an
irrational phobia of course is an
irrational fear so I have an irrational
fear of gay people yet I'm sleeping in
bed with one every night it's weird
but but that's not really it what really
I tried to do was give people the the
tools to know what will happen so not
only will you be called these things and
the Twitter mob will come for you and
whether you're a public person or not
they may come for your job you know your
your job will suddenly start getting
calls and emails and the rest of it
friends will turn on you I described
someone who was invited to my wedding
who suddenly was calling me a racist and
a bigot and a Nazi who although every
time I kept saying can you point to
anything I've said like that then they
move the goalposts they change the
meaning of the words it's not what I'm
saying it's what I'm doing it's what I'm
thinking it's what I'm who I'm talking
to and the only cure for this I think I
truly believe is that we just need more
people to be brave we have given this
paper tiger so much power over us you
know we've discussed this privately but
I don't think there is something
magically brave about me or anything
like that I don't think you think so
about yourself it's just there is
something in me that forces me to say
what I think and I think more people
need that like just think about what any
of our ancestors live through and now
we're gonna live in Canada or we're
gonna live in the United States and
because a pink anime Fox on Twitter
calls you a Nazi you're not gonna live
the life you're supposed to lead so I
know it's cliche right it's cliche just
be yourself say what you think but it
actually is true because the other part
is that they prey on the fact that they
can get you to be quiet so that the
people who do step up that eventually
they just get tired so we've even seen
this with with some of our friends at
some point certain public people that
stake out that position that that
honorable position at some point they
just get tired they're like you know
what I don't want to be in the fight
anymore because I don't get enough
allies and getting all the hate and
whatever death threats or whatever else
any of us might get
ain't that fun and we only beat them by
numbers do you do you think there's
another magic solution to it besides
that no I don't think there's a magic
solution I don't think that and either
of us is special in any way except that
we both have experience
living in the closet we both have
experience having this thoughts in our
mind and who we are on the inside
different than who we are on the outside
and we both have the experience of
having basically at some point deciding
that we've had enough of this and we
need to align our inside life and our
outside life and become truly and
honestly who we are and as difficult as
it is to go through that process it's so
incredibly rewarding and you know living
a double life is so much more insidious
and traumatic than anything that they
can throw at you once you're out and
free you know like there's no comparison
so I think that once we've been through
that and you realized okay this is it
I'm gonna be honest and I'm gonna be
real and this is who I'm gonna be for
the rest of my life and when somebody
tries to get you to go back in the
closet this time a political closet
you're not willing to go there you're
like no I've been there before
I've overcome and I'm not willing to go
down that same road again and so far you
think people have to know no good I was
just gonna say I think that people have
to experience it like they have to go
through it themselves and realize that
this turmoil that they're in right now
this fear that they're living in right
now let go I might lose my friends I
might lose my co-workers my family might
you know whatever that this turmoil that
they're in right now is way worse than
anything that the world could throw at
them when they come out it's hard for
them to understand that or believe that
because they're like what are you
talking about I lose my job I lose my
friends you know that of course this is
not worse but it is it really is it's so
interesting you say that because when
you talk about the closets that we lived
in before it was you you know not being
able to express yourself in any way and
being putting clothes that you didn't
want to be in and and this and you were
an abusive relationship and the series
of those things and for me it was about
sexuality but the the the metaphor there
or the parable I guess is that
I know that when when I was closeted and
then I would be with my friends who
didn't know who I was I started feeling
like half a person I felt a little bit
like sort of like Marty McFly you know
when the picture is disappearing at the
end of Back to the Future I felt like I
was sort of not there and you're right
it's like people think oh I could just
wait it out I'll just wait it out and
then what it's like well one day you're
gonna be 60 and you're gonna be like man
I don't like my wife I don't like my
kids I don't like any of these people
and then but the worst part I don't like
myself and I think with that that's the
part that I think young people have
trouble understanding because it just
takes a little time to you know sort of
see what the breath of life is or what
the arc of life is and it's like yeah we
just gotta keep pushing but I wanted to
ask you this because this was part of
where I wanted to go with this chapter
was one of the things that I'm actually
worried about is that they have overused
these words to the point where now if I
see someone be called a Nazi or a bigot
on Twitter I'm actually usually
interested in that person like they've
actually caused the trigger in my mind
where it's like if someone's being
assaulted first off I know that 99% of
the time they're not a Nazi I mean it's
so ridiculous but I know that they
probably didn't say anything bigoted I
know they probably didn't say anything
transphobic or any of these silly things
but what what I'm worried about for the
future is that they have done the boy
who cried wolf to the point where when
the real bad guys come when the real bad
guys come the good people are just gonna
they're just gonna be like that can't
even see they won't even want to put the
effort in to see it we're already there
we're already there I have for me you
know like just seeing the word turf now
these days thrown on everybody or you
know you know Nazi isn't quite as calm
in these days but there's different
slurs that you know that people are
throwing around and again like you I'm
like okay sure let's look into this
person let's see what they're saying and
you know sometimes that person might
actually be transphobic but because of
the fact that we have been so
desensitized
to these slurs being thrown around we
don't believe it anymore
they've completely lost their their
power they've lost their value they've
lost any meaning and yes it is scary
because now the real turfs and the real
homophobes are the real you know bigots
or the real neo-nazis are all getting
hidden in the noise
well Yasmine I know we got to end this
thing so I just want to say one last
thing to you it's well first of all just
say two last things what I wrote in the
inscription is true every idea that I
presented in this book you are the
living breathing example of it and I
couldn't be prouder to call you a friend
that's number one and number two I want
to just say one other thing it's the
nicest thing I can say to anybody
yasmin you're not a Nazi thank you Dave
you're not a Nazi they're if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell